ont pas reçu d'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
Monsieur le Premier Ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues
du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je vous
rappelle que le port du masque est
obligatoire dans notre émission
y compris pour les orateurs
un six sur deux
avec un intervalle vide
les sorties de séance se feront par
l'arrière et pour les membres du
gouvernement par le devant notre séance
est retransmise sur Public Sénat sur
notre site internet
chacun observera la foire le respect des
uns des autres le respect du temps de
parole et nous avons un certain nombre
de nos collègues qui sont présents dans
les tribunes du public ils sont donc
pleinement dans l'hémicycle pour ces
questions au Gouvernement
la parole est à madame la Présidente il
y a un assassin pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre mes chers collègues
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty a sidéré la
Nation toute entière oui en France si
souvent qualifié de pays des Lumières un
homme un enseignant a été tué
sauvagement car il transmettait le
savoir et la réflexion car il
transmettait l'humanité pour que ces
élèves deviennent demain des femmes et
des hommes libres cette humanité si
profonde qui est au cœur de la laïcité
c'est ce qu'a voulu tuer ce terroriste
au nom d'un islam radical oui l'islam
doit sortir de l'emprise intégriste
encouragée par des pays qu'il faudra
dénoncer et permettre comme ils le
souhaitent à l'immense majorité des
musulmans de pratiquer leur religion
dans la sérénité ce combat devra rejeter
les amalgames les tentatives de
récupération et de division qui se
multiplient
Samuel Paty est mort en héros il a porté
au plus haut niveau les valeurs de la
laïcité la liberté d'expression jusqu'à
en perdre la vie
son petit garçon pourra être fier de la
gloire de son père en écho assez hussard
de la République qui en début du siècle
dernier on diffusé par l'école publique
partout en France la nécessité de
l'émancipation humaine par le savoir et
la culture Monsieur le Premier Ministre
avec la nation tout entière nous devons
nous lever pour saluer la mémoire de
Samuel Patier est entouré ses proches de
notre profonde affection mais nous
devons aussi nous lever pour donner aux
enseignants enfin les moyens de leur
action essentielle pour l'avenir de
notre pays c'est hussard de la
République qu'il soit à l'école à
l'hôpital dans les mairies où les
commissariats sont trop souvent
abandonnés ils crient ou thèse leur
impuissance à remplir leur mission
monsieur le Premier ministre il n'y aura
pas de réponse à long terme au défi
sanglant du terrorisme islamique sans
une véritable reconquête républicaine
qui pose la question clé d'un choix de
société plaçant l'humain au cœur des
décisions
c'est la voix pour préserver l'unité de
la nation avec Gambetta jaffirme ce qui
constitue la vraie démocratie ce n'est
pas de reconnaître les égaux mais d'en
faire en ce jour de deuil national nous
nous inclinons devant la dépouille de
Samuel Paty mais nous portons l'espoir
que sa mort remettra en mouvement la
République laïque démocratique et
sociale pour que liberté et Progrès
règne sur notre territoire c'est là
votre devoir
Monsieur le Premier Ministre pour
répondre à la présidente
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente
c'est effectivement dans un moment
extrêmement grave et extrêmement
solennelle que je prends la parole cet
après-midi devant la Haute Assemblée en
ce jour où tout à l'heure le président
de la République présidera une cérémonie
d'hommage nationale à ce professeur
lâchement
assassiné dans des conditions
particulièrement odieuses et
inacceptable et vous l'avez rappelé de
surcroît et c'est très important madame
la présence dans l'exercice de ces
fonctions
à travers lui vous l'avez dit à travers
sa personne
c'est bien entendu la République qui est
visée
et au cœur de la République et de ses
valeurs
figurent bien sûr l'éducation nationale
la liberté
d'enseigner la liberté de penser la
liberté de s'exprimer c'est bien au-delà
de Samuel Paty la cible de cette ennemi
que nous connaissons que nous devons
nommer c'est l'islamisme politique
l'islamisme radical qui est l'un des
Terreaux du terrorisme c'est clair
les combattants
nous les connaissons
la première chose à faire madame
la première chose à faire c'est de
rester unis dans ces moments et toujours
car leur objectif
est aux arts
nous monter les uns contre les autres
affaiblir la République n'en doute pas
nous pousser
à faire ou à dire des choses qui
ramèneraient dans leur filet encore
davantage adversaires de la République
et puis nous agissons
de façon ferme et déterminée je pourrais
bien entendu détailler devant cette
assemblée
les dispositions qui ont été prises
pour donner suite et toutes les suites
à cet acte horrible mais je pourrais
surtout lui rappeler
que la prévention
de ce type d'actinium
le gouvernement est j'allais dire
l'administration de la République
il travaille depuis plusieurs années et
notamment depuis 2017
les services ont été réorganisés
les moyens ont été renforcés comme
jamais quand jadis on avait abrogé les
renseignements généraux
les lois ont été renforcés
de très nombreuses attentats grâce à ce
dispositif ont été des jouets et
l'attentat contre Monsieur Patty
dans le cadre de l'unité et du respect
de nos propres valeurs et du respect de
notre propre valeur il doit conduire à
intensifier encore davantage de façon
résolue et n'en doutez pas madame la
Présidente notre action
voyez comme va arriver à point nommé le
projet de loi annoncé aux Mureaux il y a
quelques jours par le Président de la
République pour lutter contre toute
forme de séparatisme
voyez combien
dès à présent sur l'autorité du ministre
de l'intérieur
nous allons pas simplement dans les
textes mais dans les faits encore
augmenter les moyens pour lutter contre
la haine sur Internet voyez que dès
aujourd'hui un groupement de faits qui
répand la haine a été dissout par le
Conseil des ministres et sachez que
d'autres suivront
l'éducation nationale
la République
la France finalement ont été attaqués
mais nous vaincrons madame nous
vaincrons dans l'unité et dans la
détermination parce que ces valeurs de
la République nous les partageons
nous agirons nous continuerons à agir
sans relâche pour que force reste à la
loi républicaine je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le Premier Ministre la parole
est
un peu collègue n'a déjà vu pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole
ma question
monsieur le ministre toutes nos pensées
vont à Samuel Paty assassinés parce
qu'il faisait son métier toutes nos
pensées vont à sa famille à ses élèves
et à ses collègues à tous les
professeurs qui sont retournés dans leur
classe pour accomplir la plus belle des
missions qui soit enseignée transmettre
nous le savons ils y retournent choqués
ils se sont parfois trop seuls cette
attentat terroriste islamiste
caractérisée fait suite à d'autres actes
barbares animés par la même idéologie
près de 300 morts depuis 2011 des
enfants aussi ont déjà perdu la vie face
à ce constat tragique il ne faut pas
trembler il ne faut pas de compromission
c'est une chose de le dire mais la
question de l'accompagnement au
quotidien se pose en ce même moment des
propagateurs de haine officie encore sur
les réseaux en ce même moment une
lycéenne ne peut toujours pas retourner
dans son lycée pour avoir critiqué une
religion
inimaginable inacceptable le risque face
à cela ce serait l'autocensure de
reculer collectivement parce que nous
parlons là de l'essentiel des fondements
même de notre nation la liberté de
conscience le libre examen la libre
expression l'esprit critique l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes parce que
nous parlons là de ce que nous sommes
une République laïque une et indivisible
nous savons la détermination du
gouvernement et du président de la
République a terrasser cette idéologie
mortifère la loi sur les séparatismes
arrivent bientôt au Parlement elle fera
partie de la réponse globale notre
question est la suivante monsieur le
ministre comment l'éducation nationale
doit accompagner les professeurs à
enseigner la laïcité face à des
contestations d'élèves ou de parents
violentes jusqu'à l'extrême comment
mieux les protéger dans tous leurs
enseignements qu'en est-il de leur
formation qu'en est-il de leur
encadrement
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
vous avez la parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Nadège avait je veux d'abord
vous saluer avec respect puisque vous
venez d'être élu dans la Haute Assemblée
vous dire ensuite que je partage tout ce
que vous avez dit bien entendu et dans
la lignée de ce que vient de dire le
Premier ministre je crois que nous
partageons tous ici bien entendu ce
socle de la République la liberté
d'expression étant ce pilier fondamental
pour notre République notre démocratie
et je dirais de façon plus générale la
démocratie dans le monde j'en profite
pour dire qu'il y a un immense élan de
solidarité internationale que je vois au
travers des ministres de l'éducation du
monde entier vous poser une question
très concrète et je vais vous répondre
très concrètement d'abord samedi dernier
avec le Premier ministre nous avons reçu
les organisations syndicales et ensuite
j'ai reçu les organisations
représentantes des parents d'élèves j'ai
été
non pas frappé parce que je m'y
attendais mais en tout cas très heureux
de voir que nous avions cette unité si
indispensable cette convergence de vue
sur les valeurs de la République et
cette demande des organisations
syndicales que pour le jour de la
rentrée le 2 novembre mais aussi pour
les temps à suivant nous ayons une des
consignes claire nette précise et forte
sur ce qui va se passer c'est pourquoi
j'ai demandé au Conseil des Sages de la
laïcité que j'ai créé il y a trois ans
précisément pour créer ce système de
référence dont nous avons besoin et qui
existe je lui ai demandé de siéger en
permanence pour recevoir l'ensemble des
organisations des élus qui souhaitent
être écoutés en ce moment pour faire des
propositions aussi bien sur cette
rentrée que sur la suite y compris en
matière de protection des professeurs et
donc d'ici quelques jours je donnerai
évidemment ces consignes clair net et
précis sur le déroulé du 2 d'ores et
déjà je vous en dis une
qui vous concerne directement c'est que
je demande à tous les élus de la
République des conseillers municipaux
les maires vous-même bien entendu
l'ensemble des élus de la République
d'être présent auprès des professeurs le
jour de cette rentrée ça me paraît très
important il y a d'autres mesures qui
seront prises j'aurai l'occasion
peut-être d'en reparler aujourd'hui même
je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue David insulide pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
au nom de mon groupe je veux dire notre
immense peine et solidarité à la famille
et aux proches de Samuel Paty
odieusement assassiné par un terroriste
islamiste
un professeur a été assassiné ce n'est
pas par hasard
l'islamisme politique cette extrémisme
qui ne peut ni ne doit être confondu
avec la religion musulmane de bon nombre
de nos concitoyens doublement meurtriers
aujourd'hui développe une offensive
idéologique obscurantiste contre tout ce
qu'incarne la République indivisible
sociale démocratique et laïque c'est sur
la base de ce qu'il a semé dans les
esprits par de multiples raisons
bénéficiant de nombreuses complaisances
ou aveuglement qu'un terroriste est
senti encore autorisé à tuer un
professeur a été assassiné il était de
celles et ceux qui ont quotidien avaient
pour mission de permettre à nos jeunes
de devenir des citoyennes et des
citoyens émancipés capables d'exercer
leur liberté individuelle de jugement et
d'expression de leur permettre donc
d'échapper à des assignations à
résidence communautaire familiales
culturelles religieuses sociales ou
territoriales un professeur a été
assassiné il était de celles et ceux qui
dans des conditions souvent difficiles à
contre-courant des haines qui se
déversent impunément devait expliquer
que les femmes et les hommes sont égaux
que personne ne peut être discriminé en
raison de son origine de sa religion de
sa couleur de peau ou de son orientation
sexuelle et qu'aucune loi religieuse ne
peut s'imposer à la loi de la République
un professeur a été assassiné alors je
vous demande d'affirmer avec force que
personne n'est supérieur aux professeurs
de l'école de la République laïque pour
la transmission de nos valeurs
fondamentales je vous demande aussi
d'honorer les 900 000 enseignants ces
piliers de la République en les
protégeant mieux on renforçant leurs
moyens en les valorisant aux yeux de
toute la société ce serait le meilleur
hommage à Monsieur le Professeur Samuel
Paty
pour vous répondre
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de Jeunesse et du Sport merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur David insuline je vous remercie
pour votre question là aussi nous sommes
au cœur du sujet et au cœur du sujet qui
repose sur ce socle républicain pour
nous étions témoin vous et moi puisque
nous étions côte à côte place de la
République dimanche dernier et je veux
vous saluer pour cela aussi le la
question que vous posez c'est au fond
celle de la reconnaissance des
professeurs par notre société puisque
aujourd'hui il y a un sujet de
protection bien sûr et j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir et un sujet de
reconnaissance cette question évidemment
est posée avec acuité avec cette
assassinat mais elle existait avant et
bien entendu nous devons lui apporter
une réponse c'est pourquoi depuis
plusieurs mois nous travaillons sur ce
que nous appelons l'agenda social avec
les organisations syndicales et ceci
débouche aujourd'hui sur ce que j'avais
annoncé et qui commencera demain puisque
c'était le calendrier prévu et que nous
ne le modifierons pas c'est le Grenelle
de l'éducation
ce Grenelle de l'éducation aura lieu
demain il repose sur des mots clés celui
de reconnaissance reconnaissance
financière mais aussi celui de
coopération le travail en équipe dans
notre système celui de modernisation et
celui de protection nous devons donc
développer au cours de ces trois
prochains mois un ensemble de mesures
qui feront l'objet d'une loi de
programmation ultérieurement dont
l'effet le plus visible sera
l'augmentation de la rémunération des
professeurs mais qui aura aussi d'autres
effets dès la loi dès le projet de loi
de finance 2021 que vous étudierez
bientôt vous verrez la première
augmentation avec 400 millions d'euros
consacrés à ce sujet et au-delà de cette
augmentation qui touchera notamment les
plus jeunes mais qui pourraient toucher
aussi l'ensemble des professeurs et bien
au-delà de cette augmentation c'est la
transformation de notre système
notamment pour des ressources humaines
de proximité autrement dit un système de
l'éducation nationale beaucoup moins
anonyme beaucoup plus attaché à ce qui
arrive à chaque professeur et à le
suivre dans sa carrière qui manifestera
la reconnaissance du pays à tous les
professeurs et au-delà de l'ensemble des
mesures que nous prendrons le sursaut
national que nous avons aujourd'hui doit
nous conduire à considérer que le
professeur est central dans notre
société et chacun d'entre nous dans
d'autres vies de citoyens deux parents
d'élèves nous devons tout simplement
respecter les professeurs et avoir des
discours qui mettent le professeur au
centre de notre société je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant au président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre laissez-moi
à mon tour exprimer un nom de mon groupe
notre grande émotion après cette
attentat incalifiable nos pensées vont
bien sûr vers Samuel Paty sa famille ses
proches à qui nous adressons notre
compassion elles vont aussi forte de
l'ordre qui sont intervenus dans le plus
grand professionnalisme mais je veux
aussi vous dire Monsieur le Premier
Ministre entre colère face à votre
incapacité collective à mettre un terme
au défi devenu quotidien d'une idéologie
totalitaire et mortifère assez deux
minutes de silence de marche chômage de
recul notre pays a besoin d'actes forts
pour préserver notre démocratie cartel
il y a un enjeu du combat culturel qui
se nourrit de la misère sociale et dans
lequel nous sommes entrés pour une
génération au moins aujourd'hui l'école
Le Creuset de l'avenir de notre nation
était attaquée elle enseignant a été
décapité pour avoir enseigné la liberté
d'expression rendons-nous compte sans
terrible de cette phrase j'ai été
professeur d'histoire-géographie j'ai
enseigné l'histoire de France à des
élèves de toute origine et croyances
j'ai tâché de leur transmettre ce qu'a
été l'édification de la République par
les grands principes émancipateurs des
lumières j'ai voulu qu'ils apprennent le
doute raisonnable le libre arbitre le
débat contradictoire afin qu'ils
deviennent des citoyens éclairés et des
gammes dignité quel que soit leur milieu
d'origine
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mon groupe
a toujours été depuis 1892 un défenseur
acharné de la laïcité une laïcité qui ne
peut se concevoir que sans adjectif pour
garantir de la concorde civile l'Union
nationale au-delà d'une opinion et des
croyances
une laïcité qui assure le droit de
croire ou de ne pas croire qui permet
l'égalité des chances qui ne redit pas
les individus à une vision essentialiste
une laïcité à rebours du projet
obscurantiste que les fanatiques ne
concevant la vie que par le dogme
religieux veulent nous imposer Monsieur
le Premier Ministre l'autorité de l'Etat
la cessé de reculer depuis 30 ans cela
la laïcité allez-vous enfin y mettre un
terme
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre de la
parole de ce Castex
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs et sénateurs monsieur le
Président je vous salue d'autant plus
volontiers que je sais la profession je
savais la profession que vous exerciez
et le symbole particulier qu'elle revait
aujourd'hui en ces moments difficiles
que traverse notre pays oui vous avez
raison de dire une des forces de la
République c'est qu'elle est laïque
et qu'elle va le demeurer plus que
jamais c'est un pilier de notre socle
social qu'on battu
aujourd'hui mais qu'on construit avec
ténacité nos prédécesseurs républicains
nous allons conforter la laïcité
nous le ferons d'abord je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure non seulement en ne laissant
pas impuni cet acte odieux et je
voudrais à ce stade rendre hommage à nos
forces de sécurité intérieure dois-je
rappeler à la Haute Assemblée que
l'auteur nous n'en n'avons pas parlé de
l'attentat lui aussi barbare produit
devant les anciens locaux de Charlie
Hebdo il y a quelques semaines à peine a
été arrêté par les forces de police une
heure 10 après la commission des faits
et que l'auteur de la mort sauvage de
Monsieur Paty a été neutralisé par les
forces de sécurité quelques minutes
seulement après la commission des faits
nous avons
je le dis sous l'autorité évidemment ou
sous le contrôle de l'autorité
judiciaire engagée tous les moyens
nécessaires non seulement pour que les
complices présumés de cet acte ignoble
soit poursuivi mais nous avons d'ores et
déjà pris un certain nombre de mesures
j'évoquais tout à l'heure la dissolution
d'une association je pourrais également
citer la fermeture d'une mosquée en
Seine-Saint-Denis vous l'avez suivi à
Pantin au-delà de ça au-delà de ça
monsieur sénateur nous comptons bien
dans la lutte contre le séparatisme
renforcer les valeurs de la laïcité
c'est tout l'objet notamment c'est tout
l'objet notamment de la loi dont vous
allez avoir à débattre prochainement
très précisément en début d'année
prochaine et qui sur notamment la
protection de l'école et je plus madame
Gatel ici présente qui va prolonger et
approfondir les dispositions qui avaient
été déjà votées
et que nous soumettrons à la haute
assemblée au début de l'année prochaine
nous voulons renforcer la laïcité cet
événement tragique cet événement
tragique doit nous donner l'occasion
plus fortement encore de nous rassembler
autour de cette belle valeur la
République nous ne renonçons à rien
monsieur le sénateur nous ne se
renonçons à rien notre détermination et
notre action se trouve au contraire
fortement renforcée par les événements
qui viennent de se produire
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
modique de Marco pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
merci vous avez la parole deux minutes
éducation nationale mes chers collègues
ma première pensée va la famille de
Samuel Paty sa femme et son fils la
violence de cette assassinat montre
l'immense difficulté et la mission
essentielle du métier de professeur
aujourd'hui immense difficulté car
depuis plusieurs années les enseignants
sont en première ligne face aux
événements tragiques auxquels sont
confrontées nos enfants mission
essentielle car il s'agit d'accompagner
tous les enfants de la République sur le
chemin de la connaissance et de la
réflexion gage et moyen d'une vraie
liberté de penser
l'éducation et la construction de
l'esprit critique sont les conditions de
la démocratie et de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
à côté de cette tragédie combien
d'enseignants confrontés à d'énormes
difficultés dans leur pratique
quotidiennes les relations se tendent et
trop souvent l'accompagnement le soutien
la formation manque cruellement
nous assistons à une paupérisation du
service public de l'enseignement qui
laisse aujourd'hui les professeurs seuls
garant des principes de la République
il n'y a plus de formation continue
digne de ce nom en particulier sur les
sujets de la citoyenneté du vivre
ensemble
pourtant ce besoin est réel et doit être
réalisé pendant le temps scolaire avec
des moyens de remplacement appropriés
monsieur le ministre pour avoir été
enseignante en collège pendant 30 ans
c'est avec beaucoup d'émotions et
d'inquiétudes pour l'avenir que je vous
demande quel plan de formation ambitieux
vous allez mettre en œuvre dès la
rentrée de novembre
allez-vous nous proposer un énième
numéro vert ou prendre de véritables
mesures pour accompagner comme il se
doit les professeurs face aux enjeux
actuels de notre société il est
important d'honorer la mémoire de Samuel
Paty en poursuivant son travail je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
sur le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs madame la satrices Monique
de Marco je vous salue vous aussi avec
respect puisque vous venez d'être élu et
évidemment vous posez vous aussi une
question de la plus haute importance
notamment celle de là formation des
professeurs sur ce sujet nous avons
avancé à plus d'un titre d'abord je
voudrais vous dire et nous en parlerons
au moment de le projet de loi de finance
que je faisais mes calculs hier c'est
sous ce quinquennat que vous aurez eu le
plus d'augmentation budgétaire de
l'éducation nationale si vous le
comparez même deux et trois quinquennats
précédents c'est chiffré vous le verrez
deuxième chose que je voudrais vous dire
c'est que cette assemblée a eu à
travailler sur au moins deux lois qui
ont une importance pour le sujet que
vous avez soulevé la loi Gatel bien sûr
parce que la loi Gatel en tant que
proposition de loi que j'ai très
fortement soutenu évidemment nous a
permis de faire avancer le sujet de la
laïcité mais notamment le combat contre
les écoles hors contrat correspondant à
des projets extrémistes ou radicaux
et puis la loi pour l'école de la
confiance avec des débats qui ont été
très approfondis ici sur l'enjeu de la
formation initiale et de la formation
continue et je vous donnerai en partie
raison cette formation aujourd'hui n'est
pas suffisante et nous avons commencé à
y répondre s'agissant de la formation
initiale par la systématicité de la
formation aux enjeux de l'éducation
morale et civique cette systématicité
elle fait partie désormais des enjeux de
la formation initiale en ce qui concerne
la formation continue elle doit être
beaucoup plus abondante
je ne parlerai que de l'éducation morale
et civique mais bien sûr nous pourrions
parler de l'ensemble des autres sujets
par exemple de ce que nous faisons en
français et mathématiques en ce moment
même pour les savoirs fondamentaux à
l'école primaire mais s'agissant de
l'éducation morale et civique nous
l'avons renforcé et nous allons la
renforcer y compris pour lui donner un
caractère plus vivant plus tonique pour
avoir des élèves engagés dans ces enjeux
civiques ce qui va de pair aussi avec
d'autres initiatives que je prendrai en
tant que ministre de la Jeunesse pour
l'engagement civique des élèves mais
cette formation continue elle correspond
aussi à des outils pédagogiques aussi à
des formations à distance canopée a
développé un programme sur la laïcité à
distance qu'il est en train d'enrichir
encore plus de façon à ce que ces enjeux
de l'éducation morale et civique soient
appropriées non seulement par les
professeurs d'histoire-géographie mais
par l'ensemble du corps professoral car
c'est aussi un des enjeux que
l'éducation morale et civique soit
portée d'abord par l'histoire-géographie
mais aussi par l'ensemble du corps
professoral je vous remercie
de Marco quelques secondes si vous le
souhaitez
non oui oui je pense monsieur le Premier
ministre qui est nécessaire monsieur le
ministre qu'il est nécessaire d'élargir
l'information donc à l'ensemble des
enseignants et pas seulement sur
l'histoire géographie ensuite je ne
pense pas que la formation à distance
dans ce cas-là soit suffisante je pense
qu'il faut une formation très vaste et
en présentiel parce que les enseignants
ont besoin de formation dans ce domaine
et tous les enseignants
la parole est au président Claude malré
pour le gros plaisant République et
territoire vous avez la parole
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ce n'est
plus seulement dans les mosquées
salafistes que ce recrutent les
djihadistes c'est aussi sur l'Internet
devenu l'écosystème du complotisme de la
haine et désormais des influenceurs
islamistes
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty a été
préparée par les torrents d'injures des
fanatiques sur les réseaux antisociaux
il y a aussi sur ce réseau ce qui
fracture méthodiquement notre pays les
Identitaires les racialistes les
indigénistes les décoloniaux et il y a
enfin les idiots utiles qui créent à
l'islamophobie ou racisme dès qu'on
annonce des mesures pour combattre
l'islamisme
l'Assemblée nationale a voté la loi qui
imposait le retrait des contenus haineux
dans les 24 heures cette loi a été
censurée par le Conseil constitutionnel
au nom de la liberté d'expression cette
censure laisse le problème entier la
liberté d'expression ne consiste pas à
mettre en ligne la haine le harcèlement
les appels au meurtres ou le djihadisme
la loi interdit à la presse de publier
de tels contenus et la presse s'y
conforme sans que personne n'y voit une
atteinte à la liberté d'expression les
plateformes elles sont exonère sans
aucune sanction les résultats sont sous
nos yeux monsieur le Premier ministre
vous avez annoncé hier la création un
délit de mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui par Internet pourquoi pas mais
il faut aller plus loin la seule façon
de nettoyer le dépotoir des réseaux
antisociaux le torrent debout disait le
président archer et l'obligation du
retrait des contenus haineux il faut
absolument y revenir sous une forme
acceptable par le Conseil
constitutionnel nous le devons à Sonia
Mabrouk Hamila a Zineb El razaoui et
attend d'autres obligé de vivre chaque
jour sous protection policière à cause
des patois sur Internet et le meilleur
hommage à Samuel Paty au-delà des
commémorations c'est de continuer avec
des lois enfin efficaces le cours qu'il
donnait à ses élèves ce cours par lequel
il luttait contre la haine et pour
l'unité de la République
pour vous répondre
la parole est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre
ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur président malgré
je partage l'intégralité du contenu de
la question que vous avez bien voulu me
poser
on voit en effet
se conforter un profil de criminel qui
passe à l'acte en réalité sous l'effet
de deux effecteurs
d'abord une manipulation qui passe
souvent par des associations qui a le
même ce camoufle sous un objet sportif
sous un objet éducatif
parfois sous un objet culturel et qui
sont en réalité des instruments de
l'islam politique et puis deuxième
source de manipulation vous l'avez dit
et les réseaux sociaux globalement
entendu
il faut donc impérativement je vous
rejoins tout à fait nous attaquer plus
fortement encore à ceux qui manipulent
et à ceux qui transmettent la haine
nous allons donc
nous allons donc dans le cadre actuel
déjà renforcé le Conseil des ministres
l'a fait aujourd'hui les dissolates les
dissolutions d'associations ou de
groupements de faits et proposer à la
représentation nationale d'élargir les
cas légaux ou ces dispensés dissolutions
pourront intervenir mais vous l'avez dit
il y a aussi toute la question de la
haine en ligne
du recours aux réseaux sociaux
vous avez
emprunté à monsieur le Président du
Sénat une appréciation
dans laquelle je me retrouve volontiers
sur ces réseaux et sur tout sur le
recours que certains enfants
vous savez que nous avons en réalité
deux sujets non seulement effectivement
une jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel que vous avez rappelé et
que je crois l'ensemble de la Haute
Assemblée connaît nous avons aussi des
sujets de directives communautaire à
faire évoluer pour mieux responsabiliser
les hébergeurs
je serai sachez-le dès vendredi à
Bruxelles pour rencontrer plusieurs
commissaires et la présidente de la
Commission européenne et c'est l'un des
premiers sujets que je vais aborder avec
elle nous avons déjà pris avant même les
terribles faits dont nous parlons cet
après-midi des initiatives sur le champ
communautaire ça sera une de nos
premières priorités et puis
effectivement dans le texte
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et vous
avez bien voulu faire référence à mon
intervention hier devant l'Assemblée
nationale il nous faut et je suis sûr
que le Sénat y concourra trouver une
voie juridique
tenant compte de la jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel il n'appartient
pas au Premier ministre de commenter les
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
mais rendant beaucoup plus effectif vous
avez raison notre action déterminée
contre la haine sur les réseaux sociaux
je vous remercie merci
la parole est maintenant au président
Bruno retaillod pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le Premier ministre
en France aujourd'hui on peut être
décapité seulement pour avoir fait un
cours d'instruction civique sur la
liberté d'expression en France
aujourd'hui des fatsois sont lancés et
la charia immédiatement exécutée mais
cette fois-ci quelque chose a changé
parce que les Français sont passés
presque instantanément d'un état de
sidération un état de colère il
demandait compte ils exigent des
résultats tout simplement parce qu'ils
sentent confusément il le sentent bien
que nous sommes en train de perdre le
combat contre le totalitarisme islamiste
faute de courage souvent
faute aussi de mener un combat global un
combat global contre l'islamisme sous
toutes ses formes sa forme violente ces
formes rampantes un combat global aussi
contre le désordre migratoire qui en est
l'un des Terreaux qui est un défi un
obstacle à l'assimilation de nos valeurs
républicaines Monsieur le Premier
Ministre êtes-vous prêts êtes-vous prêt
à mener ce combat qui doit être global
vous venez nous parler d'un texte qui
nous arrivera dans 5 mois au mois de
février prochain ce texte-ci
comportera-t-il oui ou non des mesures
pour remédier à ce désordre migratoire
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
[Applaudissements]
chez le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
et sénateurs monsieur le Président
Retailleau
vous avez dit à juste titre les Français
ont été sidérés les Français sont en
colère je crois que nous le sommes
toutes et tous il n'y a pas de doute
là-dessus et le gouvernement de la
République que j'ai l'honneur de diriger
il n'est pas simplement sidéré ou en
colère il est déterminé et à la manœuvre
déterminer et à la manœuvre alors
j'entends je le regrette je vous le dis
tout de suite que nous soyons
questionnés sur notre prétendu
inefficacité c'est sans doute le débat
démocratique et j'en accepte bien
entendu toutes les conditions
mais vous mesurez bien que les choses
sont difficiles et que d'autre part et
que d'autre part dans les finalités de
ceux qui combattent la République je le
répète il y a aussi la volonté de faire
éclater la communauté nationale n'en
doutez pas un seul instant n'en doutez
pas un seul instant donc nous agissons
nous agissons j'ai ici le ministre de
l'Intérieur pourra y revenir tout ce qui
notamment sur le champ du renseignement
sur le champ du renseignement vous avez
parlé de l'immigration mais je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que c'est fait
et nous avons des chiffres peuvent être
commis peuvent être le fait peuvent être
répandus par des personnes étrangères
mais également malheureusement par des
citoyens de la République
donc notre action elle est tous azimute
elle est tous azimute et il faut les
identifier c'est la première chose il
faut les identifier pour les empêcher de
passer à l'acte nous avons renforcé
considérablement leur enseignement nous
allons nous attaquer aux efflecteurs
encore plus forts comme je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure et nous prendrons toutes les
mesures vous m'entendrez bien toutes les
mesures nous n'hésitons à aucun moment
de le faire notre main n'a jamais
tremblé et la mienne en particulier
croyez le bien ne tremblera pas
monsieur le Président rotaïo mais
monsieur le Premier ministre c'est vous
c'est votre gouvernement qui fait le
lien entre l'islamisme le terrorisme et
l'immigration puisque les premières
annonces du ministre de l'aviron les
premières annonces étaient des
expulsions d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière ce que vous ce que nous vous
demandons c'est le courage de réarmer la
République mais nous vous demandons
aussi de faire aimer la France ne cédez
pas ne cédez pas vraiment ne cédez pas
la tentation quelle est la tentation si
française de la pénitence perpétuelle il
faut faire aimer la France ne désignez
pas la France comme un coupable
perpétuel
ne faites pas comme le président de la
République en indiquant que la France
est coupable du crime contre l'humanité
le pire des crimes Monsieur le Premier
Ministre oui il faut réarmer la
République il faut aussi faire aimer la
France relevons ensemble les temps d'art
de nous couleurs de nos valeurs relevons
ensemble aussi l'étendard de la fierté
française
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant
à notre collègue Loïc Hervé
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur
la France est un État de droit et
l'entend le rester alors notre pays ne
doit pas être faible nous devons être
capables de faire appliquer les
décisions de la justice ou de
l'administration des milliers
d'étrangers qui sont des prêcheurs de
haine et veulent abattre les principes
de notre République continuent de vivre
sur notre sol des décisions les ont
pourtant condamnées à quitter notre
territoire national ils sont nombreux
trop nombreux à être toujours là
une immense majorité de nos concitoyens
près d'une colère froide se pose cette
question pourquoi sont-ils encore là à
cette question mille fois posée on nous
a mille fois répondu ah oui mais vous
comprenez c'est compliqué
après ce nouvel attentat atroce contre
Samuel Paty qui nous a tous touché très
profondément vous allez être tenté de
proposer à nouveau Parlement de durcir
notre arsenal juridique et d'aggraver
les peines en réalité l'affaiblissement
de l'État n'en serait que renforcé car
le premier problème c'est l'application
ferme et systématique du droit alors
nous savons tous que ce n'est pas le cas
plus qu'un constat d'impuissance est un
terrible aveu le président de la
République a annoncé vouloir prendre des
mesures concrètes et rapides monsieur
ministre de l'Intérieur vous avez
d'ailleurs indiqué dimanche que 231
étrangers dangereux allaient être
expulsés pouvez-vous prendre
l'engagement de revenir dans un mois
nous dire combien sont effectivement
partis et pouvez-vous nous donner de la
visibilité pour les mois qui viennent
pour vos réponses
la parole est au ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur Darmanin vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je suis tout à fait prêt à
venir devant toutes les commissions que
vous souhaitez évidemment par définition
par construction mais aussi par
conviction pour répondre à cette
importante
est difficile question et ma motivation
est complète permettez-moi d'abord avant
de vous répondre sur le fond après avoir
répondu à votre invitation avoir une
pensée également pour les policiers qui
ont été en première ligne sur l'attentat
devant les anciens locaux de Charlie
Hebdo comme devant l'attentat qui s'est
déroulée de façon ignoble près de ce
collège à chaque fois ce sont des
policiers qui en moins de 10 15 20
minutes sont intervenus et ont pu soin
interpeller soit mettre fin si j'ose
dire à la cavalcade mortelle de ce
terroriste il risque si la vie vous le
savez bien et je sais qu'ils ont votre
conviction et votre salut je voudrais
dire monsieur le sénateur que faisons
malheureusement un lien entre votre
question et la question du président
retaillou et malheureusement nous
répondons pas puisque vous demandez des
comptes et je l'entends et je suis
normalement là pour y répondre je le
ferais bien volontiers contre l'idée que
Monsieur patine n'était pas encore
enterré que nous posions déjà des
questions je veux bien faire une
comparaison
vous savez que depuis 2018 c'est sous le
président Macron qu'on a créé le fichier
de fftrt pour savoir quels étrangers
étaient dans ce fichier et depuis trois
ans c'est 436 étrangers en situation
régulière qui ont été expulsés et qui
était radicalisé vous savez que en 5 ans
entre 2007 et 2012 mais les choses
étaient très différentes et moi je ne
fais pas pour faire attention je note
cependant qui avait que 24 expulsions et
alors que en trois ans entre 2007 et
2010 sur les personnes qui étaient en
trouble à l'ordre public c'était 106
expulsion x 5 sous le président Macron
sans doute dans d'autres circonstances
j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses sur les
interpellations de situation étrangère
en situation illégale
74000 sur le gouvernement de François
Fillon 125 000 sous le gouvernement
d'Édouard Philippe je crois
qu'effectivement nous pourrions comparer
nos chiffres
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur Hervé
monsieur le ministre aucun humanisme
tiendra le choc si la République ne fait
pas appliquer le droit et ne met pas en
œuvre les mesures que le Parlement a
permis dans la loi en somme si l'État ne
fait pas appliquer les peines ce premier
ministre décidé par les juges dans notre
pays
alors si certaines personnes étrangères
condamnées sont toujours sur notre sol
dans un mois faudra nous expliquer
pourquoi si ce sont des raisons
juridiques alors il faudra nous dire
précisément et modifier la loi si ce
sont des raisons diplomatiques il faudra
l'expliquer également aux Français et
prendre toutes mesures pour que ces
obstacles là soient levés j'ai
conscience qu'on répondant à ces
questions on ne traite qu'une partie du
problème beaucoup de ces prêcheurs de
Enzo français comme vous et moi mais
renvoyons d'abord au dehors de nos
frontières ceux qui méritent de l'être
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Pacaud pour le groupe les républicains
vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale ainsi qu'au garde des sceaux
si je suis sénateur je reste le
professeur d'histoire-géographie que
j'ai été comme d'autres ici vendredi un
enseignant d'histoire-géographie Samuel
Paty a été sacrifié sur l'Hôtel du
fanatisme islamiste ce fascisme
d'aujourd'hui condamné à devenir martyr
pour avoir accompli son devoir enseigner
la tolérance tenter d'éveiller les
consciences décapiter pour avoir
simplement fait son métier transmis à
savoir l'histoire et ça fait naturelle
l'éducation civique sont des matières
plus que précieuses parce qu'elle révèle
nos racines donne un sens au long fil
d'Ariane qui nous relie à nos aïeux
parce qu'elle nous permettent de
comprendre mieux comment vivre ensemble
mieux vaut savoir d'où l'on vient pour
ne pas se perdre et s'égarer sur les
sentiers du malheur d'aller à la leçon
de vie le talisman prudent coffre
l'histoire et ses professeurs or depuis
des années ceux qui enseigne l'histoire
à l'éducation civique sont parfois s'est
passé on veut les faire taire la Shoah
les croisades les valeurs républicaines
la laïcité les droits de l'homme la
femme à l'égale de l'homme les
islamistes veulent en effacer les traces
aveugler les esprits et certaines
autorités ne veulent surtout pas de
vagues pensaient que Samuel Paty avait
été convoqué au commissariat pour se
justifier aussi est-il temps de
réellement protéger les professeurs de
sanctuariser les cours d'histoire et
d'instruction civique mais aussi de
sciences de l'être de sport monsieur le
ministre ne doit-on pas désormais
instaurer un délit d'entrave à la
liberté d'enseigner dans le cadre
évidemment des programmes définis par
l'Éducation nationale c'est un des
moyens pour faire cesser la guérilla
permanente des ennemis de l'école
émancipatrice
pour vous répondre la parole est tôt
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs Olivier Pacaud merci d'avoir
fait référence aux professeurs
d'histoire-géographie parce que au-delà
de tout le match que nous rendons au
professeurs regardons ce que les enjeux
qu'il y a derrière cette discipline et
derrière l'action de chacun des
professeurs c'est un sujet dont je
parlais ce matin même encore avec
l'association des professeurs
d'histoire-géographie venu m'apporter
son soutien et ses propositions dans les
circonstances d'unités nationales qui
sont les circonstances que les faits
obligent à noter et à avoir
les professeurs d'histoire-géographie
vous avez raison sont souvent en
première ligne ce qui d'ailleurs ne
devrait pas être le cas parce que tous
les enseignements et malheureusement
dans le cas des enseignements
scientifiques nous savons aussi qui peut
y avoir des problèmes tous les
enseignements sont en première ligne de
la défense de la République et de la
transmission des valeurs de la
République la seule chose que je ne peux
pas vous laisser dire c'est qu'il n'y a
pas eu de soutien de l'institution à
Monsieur parce que depuis trois ans et
demi ce que nous avons fait c'est la
création du Conseil des Sages de la
laïcité vous avez désormais un système
de normes sur la laïcité de référence
extrêmement exigeants de l'éducation
nationale deuxièmement des équipes
valeurs de la laïcité de la République
pardon elles sont intervenues dans cette
affaire en soutien de Monsieur Patty et
je vous en supplie ne relayez pas les
mensonges les fake news et réseaux
sociaux alors même qu'à l'instant on
vient de dire que c'était l'un des pires
l'une des pires choses de notre époque
ce n'est pas vrai de dire qu'il n'y a
pas eu de soutien de l'institution
l'effet le démontreront l'inspection
générale et bien entendu les autorités
judiciaires vous donneront toutes les
informations mais je vous en supplie ne
faites pas ce que justement on peut
reprocher aux ennemis de la République
il est extrêmement important de dire que
la logique du fameux pas de vagues n'est
pas ou n'est plus si vous préférez la
logique de l'éducation nationale je l'ai
dit dès les premiers jours de mon
arrivée il y a 3 ans et demi je l'ai
démontré et dans cette affaire ce n'est
pas le pas de vague qui est en question
bien sûr il y a les problèmes et je suis
le premier à le dire et je suis le
premier à les nommer ces problèmes
existent bel et bien nous n'avons pas
tout résolu il y a encore beaucoup à
faire notamment pour encore mieux
signaler et encore mieux réagir c'est ce
que nous avons commencé à faire c'est ce
que nous ferons davantage encore je suis
ouvert à toutes les propositions pour
aller plus loin mais la logique elle est
bien celle du signalement elle est bien
celle de la défense sans faille des
principes de la République
ce Paco quelques secondes
vous ne m'avez pas répondu sur le délit
d'entrave alors oui nous sommes en
guerre oui la peur doit changer de camp
oui la foi ne saurait être au-dessus de
la loi mais si la parole a des vertus
elle a des faiblesses la République doit
éclairer mais aussi protégée alors
commençons par modifier l'article 431 du
code j'ai une proposition de loi
elle est à votre disposition Charles par
course quoi disait jadis il faut
terroriser les islamistes les
terroristes pourraient dire qu'il faut
se séparer des séparatistes aujourd'hui
il faut paralyser les islamistes
la parole est à notre collègue
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre mes chers collègues
chacun ici a soutenu voire participer à
des gouvernements qui ont dû faire face
au terrorisme
cela doit et je m'adresse également au
président Retailleau cela doit tous nous
engager à l'humilité et à la
responsabilité
dans une période troublée violente il
est d'autant plus nécessaire d'être
clair sur les principes le premier
principe est que la France est un État
de droit c'est-à-dire où la norme
s'applique et où l'arbitraire n'a pas sa
place or depuis vendredi Monsieur le
Premier Ministre votre Ministre de
l'Intérieur dit vouloir intimider passer
des messages
usant pour se faire de pouvoir qui
trouveront rapidement leurs limites et
assume une forme d'arbitraire le garde
des sceaux tout d'abord discret absent
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui semble lui prêt à
modifier la loi fondatrice de la liberté
de la presse et de la liberté
d'expression du 29 juillet 1881
permettez-moi Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de vous rappeler les propos
tenus par Robert baninter au lendemain
de l'attentat contre Charlie ce n'est
pas par des lois et des juridictions
d'exception qu'on défend la liberté
contre ses ennemis ce serait là un piège
que l'histoire a déjà attendu au
démocratie celle qui ont cédé ni rien
gagné en efficacité répressive mais
beaucoup ont perdu en termes de liberté
et parfois d'honneur alors Monsieur le
Premier Ministre dans cette période le
et en même temps ne peut vous guider
davantage ma question est simple
entendez-vous écornez notre État de
droit ou au contraire vous y référer
toujours dans un face à face courageux
avec les Français
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
merci Monsieur président madame la
sénatrice
j'applique les lois votées par le
Parlement et saguirement les excellentes
lois qu'elle jadis vous souteniez celle
de Monsieur Cazeneuve et de Monsieur
Valls à l'époque
regardant et préparant ces questions
d'actualité vous n'y étiez pas très
opposé sans doute que le changement de
ministre vous encourage peut-être à dire
de vos oppositions
madame la sénatrice lors du débat il y a
pas plus tard que quelques jours au
Sénat monsieur le Président alors même
que cet attentat odieux n'avait pas été
perpétré avec le président buffet avec
le rapporteur au marché de Brest nous
avions un échange justement sur la loi
silt et votre groupe n'a pas voté les
dispositions qui aident justement les
services de renseignement les services
de police à lutter contre des
terroristes
madame la sénatrice
madame la sénatrice les 80 opérations de
police que j'ai effectivement commandé
parce que figurez-vous qu'à mini zones
intérieur il commande la police et la
gendarmerie ont tout été autorisé par le
juge des libertés et à chaque opération
je suis allé voir pas intermédiaire du
DGSI du DGPN ou du DGGN le juge des
libertés et les juges de liberté partout
sur le territoire ont autorisé ces
opérations et madame la sénatrice je
suis à la disposition encore une fois du
Parlement pour rendre compte de toutes
ces opérations devant n'importe quelle
commission vous souhaitez parce que
j'applique la loi de la République
c'est-à-dire la loi forte de l'État pour
protéger les petites gens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je regrette monsieur le ministre que
vous n'ayez pas affirmé votre
attachement à l'état de droit vous étiez
enfant et donc n'ayez pas encore entamé
votre vie de jeune homme lorsque un
illustre prédécesseur membre du Sénat
avait annoncé qu'il allait terroriser
les terroristes et que l'insécurité
allait changer de camp 4 mois plus tard
l'attentat de la rue de Rennes voyait 7
morts et 51 blessés donc vous devez être
conscient aujourd'hui de la gravité du
sujet qui est saisi et quand vous allez
y compris pour réglementer la
disposition des étals de supermarché
vous n'êtes pas exactement dans votre
rôle et je ne suis pas sûr vous
respecter l'état de droit
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
et musique pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
donc Charles Pasqua avait raison
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres collègues ma
question s'adresse au Premier ministre
au nom des Français qui ont appris avec
effroi la décapitation de Samuel Paty un
grand de plus dans l'abomination dans la
volonté des ayatollahs de l'islam imposé
leur loi chez nous et Luca dans 30 ans
j'en ai vu et entendu des renoncements
j'ai aussi vu cette idéologie
totalitaire gagner nos quartiers
encouragé par la lâcheté coupable de
politique et aussi de technocrate on a
fermé les yeux sur les migrations
massives liées regroupement familial sur
la création de ghetto urbains sur la
dérive de ces quartiers gangrenés par la
drogue de communautarisme et l'islamisme
on a fermé les yeux sur la motivation
réelle de certains migrants qui viennent
pour porter la haine et le sang on a
fermé les yeux sur les coups de canifs à
la laïcité les repas substitutions les
prières de rue les couloirs dans les
piscines le port du voile dans l'espace
public autant de coups de boutoir porter
contre les fondements de notre
République mais aujourd'hui vous pouvez
pas les fermer les yeux le Premier
ministre parce que l'horreur vous a
sauté au visage comme un de tous
d'ailleurs parce qu'il s'est passé à
Conflans la même chose Caracas ou à
Mossoul alors que fait-on aujourd'hui
les Français ont compris qu'alumait des
bougies et défiler dans la rue n'étaient
pas à rempart contre cette ennemi qui
veut imposer la charia au ventre mou de
l'Occident les Français attendent de
vous des actes forts la mise en place
d'une immigration choisie et non pas
imposée par des juges irresponsables
l'expulsion des clandestins et des
délinquants étrangers une application
sans faille des règles de la laïcité la
déchéance de nationalité contre tous
ceux qui prennent les armes contre la
mer patrie la reconquête ru par rue de
toutes les zones de non-droits un
soutien total à la police ici nécessaire
le renfort de l'armée pour cela il faut
un exécutif
déterminé un parlement respecté que
représentant légitime du peuple il ne
passeront pas à déclarer le président de
la République le combat a donc enfin
commencé chez nous espérons-le alors
Monsieur le Premier Ministre dites-nous
quelles armes avec quelles armes nous
allons combattre et comment nous pouvons
gagner cette guerre plus de renoncement
des actes s'il vous plaît
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin
monsieur le Président Madame Monsieur
les sénateurs monsieur sénateur benzak
si on peut être d'accord sur le constat
on peut différer sur quelques-unes de
vos solutions
d'abord vous faites un lien que j'ai
déjà entendu plusieurs fois pas dans
tous les représentants du groupe les
républicains mais dans quelques-uns qui
consiste à dire étranger égalista mista
= problème
= terrorisme
quand on dit qu'on arrête totalement
l'immigration permettez-moi de vous dire
c'est que vous pensez par nature que
tout étranger qui vient sur le sol
national pourrait être un problème
pardon de vous dire qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui fuient des dictatures
islamistes pour prendre le droit d'asile
en France des tas de jeunes femmes qui
viennent à l'OFPRA demandaient le droit
d'asile pour pouvoir justement porter
cheveux au vent dans la rue et donc
cette caricature me semble-t-il y
compris d'immigrations qui viennent de
certains pays arabes n'onore pas y
compris même l'idée que vous faites de
l'affirmation de la laïcité et la
vocation universelle de la France
la deuxième des choses c'est que si à
procès à faire sur les naturalisations
et je ne pense pas qu'il prend ça à
faire sur naturisation c'est celui
peut-être de la majorité monsieur le
députateur que nous avons soutenu moi
jeune militants vous parlementaire 84000
naturalisation par an entre 2007 et 2012
54000 naturalisations par an sous le
président Macron
peut-être que cette erreur était
ancienne et que vous faisiez en fait
votre propre pensée puisque en regardant
bien
en regardant bien la famille la famille
la famille de ce terroriste est arrivé
en France sous le président Chirac
elle a eu ses papiers sous le président
Sarkozy elle n'a pas été expulsée sous
le président Hollande et le commun
attentat sur le président Macron
peut-être monsieur le sénateur que la
question finalement est simple à poser
les réponses sont difficiles qu'il faut
beaucoup de courage sans doute beaucoup
de courage sans doute pour réparer
beaucoup d'erreurs du passé et c'est
pour ça que c'est un gros honneur d'être
ministre de l'Intérieur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Olivier gigolotti pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
Jacqueline Gouraud ministre de la
cohésion des territoires madame la
ministre le groupe Union centriste ne
remet pas en cause la baisse des impôts
de production qui est l'une des mesures
phares du projet de budget pour 2021
nous ne remettons pas en cause la
pertinence de ce choix il relève presque
du bon sens pour relocaliser
réindustrialiser et relancer il faut
effectivement alléger la fiscalité des
entreprises le problème c'est que le
gouvernement a choisi encore une fois de
ne pas baisser la fiscalité locale la
CVAE la cot la CFE la taxe foncière sur
le bâti le tout pour 10 milliards
d'euros on ne touche donc pas à la part
des impôts de l'État la taxe sur les
salaires la C3S ou le forfait social
c'est toujours la même logique qui est à
l'oeuvre celle ayant déjà présidé à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
fiscalité locale est mise en coupe
réglée
le ministre des comptes publics nous a
bien assuré que la baisse des impôts de
production serait je le cite compensé
intégralement et de manière dynamique
pour les collectivités donc acte mais
cette politique sape encore une fois en
profondeur le principe d'autonomie
fiscale des communautés de communes ou
d'agglomération lorsque l'on perçoit des
dotations
lorsque aussi dynamique soit elle pardon
on devient dépendant d'un état
centralisateur supprimer les impôts
locaux c'est transformer les
collectivités en simple guichet car sans
fiscalité propre on ne perçoit plus de
retour sur investissement et on a donc
plus beaucoup plus beaucoup de moyens
pardon plus beaucoup de moyens et plus
beaucoup de raisons de faire des efforts
madame la ministre on ne peut pas à la
fois prétendre faire confiance au
territoire et aux élus locaux et
poursuivre ainsi ma question est la
suivante comment madame la ministre
entendez-vous restaurer une fois pour
toutes l'autonomie fiscale
pour
les collectivités merci pour vos
réponses la madame Jacqueline Gourault
au ministre de la cohésion des
territoires merci monsieur le président
sénateur monsieur le sénateur Olivier
sigolotti vous avez comparé toutes les
impôts je voudrais d'abord commencer par
dire que la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation est un engagement du
Président de la République et qu'il
avait pour but d'alléger les impôts sur
les Français et c'est une chose bien sûr
et vous pouvez le constater je pense que
pendant les campagnes qui ont eu lieu
récemment personne n'a défendu ou n'a
contrarié ce principe de la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation
pas auprès de la population pas auprès
de la population comme vous le savez les
impôts de production
baisseront de 10 milliards effectivement
en 2021 la suppression de la part
régional de la CVAE et la réduction de
moitié des impôts fonciers des locaux
industriels bien sûr le gouvernement
s'est engagé à ce que les collectivités
locales soient intégralement et de façon
pérenne et dynamique compensée pour les
régions pour les régions elles recevront
dès 2021 une fraction de TVA égale à la
CVAE perçue et c'est un accord passé
avec l'Association des régions de France
deuxièmement pour les communes et les
intercommunalités nous inscrivons dans
la loi un prélèvement sur les recettes
de l'État dont le Manta sera strictement
égal au montant des impôts que la
collectivité aurait touché
ce n'est pas une dotation
budgétaire c'est un prélèvement sur
recettes c'est un gage bien sûr pour les
élus locaux hier dans cette assemblée
nous avons eu déjà un débat très
intéressant qu'il faut poursuivre entre
l'autonomie fiscale et l'autonomie
financière c'est un vrai débat de fond
je vois par exemple les régions qui ont
accepté bien sûr des fractions de TVA
c'est-à-dire de part d'impôts national
je reconnais que pour les collectivités
territoriales que sont les communes le
fait de lever l'impôt et quelque chose
de très important et que sur l'impôt
foncier c'est encore bien sûr François
les impôts fonciers mais c'est un débat
qu'il faudra avoir ensemble
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Bruno Belin pour le groupe les
républicains vous avez la parole
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues Monsieur le Premier Ministre
ma question s'adressait à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé
je ne vais pas vous parler monsieur le
ministre d'un virus inconnu encore de
tous il y a quelques mois venu du bout
du monde et pour lequel nous n'aurions
pas été prêts
je vous parle d'un virus dans la
puissance contagieuse est connue de tous
mondialement depuis 1918 et pour lequel
un vaccin existe depuis 1944
chacun sait la virulence contagieuse la
virulence saisonnière du virus de la
grippe or nous ne sommes pas prêts nous
ne sommes pas prêts trois chiffres
7 millions de Français ont d'ores et
déjà retiré en pharmacie
un vaccin
inquiet par la situation sanitaire qui
nous entoure 15 millions de personnes
bénéficieront d'un prise en charge en
fonction de leur situation à risque
or 13 millions de doses vaccinales ont
été seulement préparés
que comptez-vous faire monsieur le
ministre pour protéger les habitants de
ce pays pour éviter la rupture de stock
en officine dès cette semaine alors que
nous entrons dans la période optimale
pour se faire vacciner
pour vous répondre la parole des au
secrétaire d'État
adriaque vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Belin permettez-moi tout
d'abord de vous féliciter pour votre
élection récente et je suis ravi d'avoir
l'honneur de répondre à votre première
question en tant que sénateur car j'ai
apprécié j'ai apprécié le travail que
nous avons pu mener ensemble l'année
dernière en tant que président du
conseil départemental de la Vienne sur
la protection de la protection de
l'enfance alors cette campagne de
vaccination vous l'avez évoqué à débuter
le 13 octobre dernier elle se poursuivra
jusqu'au 31 janvier prochain et votre
question est la presse a fait écho d'un
certain nombre de questions qui sont
légitimes d'une part tout le monde
doit-il se faire vacciner et aurons-nous
suffisamment de deux vaccins alors
concernant la première la première des
interrogations rappeler à la rotation de
la Haute Autorité de Santé a rendu dès
le 20 mai dernier avis qui confirmait
que cette vaccination soit ça doit
s'adresser priorité aux professionnels
de santé aux personnes les plus fragiles
notamment les personnes âgées et celles
qui sont à risque d'infection grave à la
covid-19 vaccinations et professionnelle
répond à un double objectif que je me
permets de rappeler ici pour rappeler
aussi au professionnel de la nécessité
de ce vacciner pour protéger tout
d'abord les protéger et leur permettre
de continuer à assurer leur activité de
soins et donc soulager l'ensemble du
système de soins mais également protéger
les patients avec lesquels ils sont en
contact et notamment dans les hôpitaux
dans les établissements médico-sociaux
et dans les EHPAD concernant le nombre
de doses disponibles ensuite qui se
réfère à la question plus précisément
que vous posez me permettre de rappeler
que l'objectif de cette campagne
vaccinale n'est pas que 100% des
Français soient vaccinés mais 75%
conformément aux recommandations de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé et
compte tenu de l'anticipation d'une
demande accrue cette année nous avons
fait le nécessaire pour mettre à
disposition 30% de doses supplémentaires
par rapport aux 12 millions consommés
lors de la précédente campagne ça sera
dura par un approvisionnement continue
nous avons bien conscience phénomène de
tension qui peut exister dans certaines
officines mais ces zones seront
constituées par les vaccins qui sont
commandés par les officines par les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques ou encore
les établissements de santé mais aussi
pour la première fois par la
constitution d'un stock d’état je peux
donc vous assurer monsieur le sénateur
que l'État fait tout pour protéger nos
concitoyens contre cette épidémie de
grippe
je crains que nous devions le pays de la
pénurie pénurie de médecin pénurie de
moyens dans les hôpitaux pénurie de
masques pénurie de gel pénurie de sur
blues pénurie de test pénurie de l'Hydra
réanimation pénurie d'anticipation ce
qui est encore plus grave
pénurie de vaccin l'impréparation est
une faute monsieur le ministre j'espère
que nous allons nous mobiliser les uns
et les autres pour que il y ait moins de
pénurie et d'incurie dans ce pays
et
et la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Yves Leconte pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vendredi dernier Samuel Paty
enseignant dans un collège public fut
victime d'un attentat terroriste
islamique lâchement assassiné avec la
plus grande Barbie il a payé de sa ville
à défense et l'enseignement de la
liberté d'expression de la laïcité des
valeurs de notre République il a payé de
sa vie l'exercice d'un métier qui le
passionnait celui d'instruire et
d'éduquer nos enfants avec le groupe
socialiste écologique et républicain je
joins évidemment ma voie à l'hommage qui
lui est dû une de ses anciens élèves
indiquait hier quand il entendait une
remarque agressive contre moi en cours
il intervenait immédiatement pour me
protéger je n'arrive pas à croire que
personne n'a réussi à le protéger lui
nous potons nous nous posons monsieur le
ministre tous cette question
car nous disposons d'un arsenal
juridique complet et de dispositions
législatives et réglementaires
spécifiques permettant en théorie au
pouvoir administratif et judiciaire de
prévenir la monastère or en l'espèce
suite aux appels à la haine à la
campagne non songée à la diffamatoire et
aussi béracellement dont il a été
victime et bien que des protagonistes
étaient fichés nos services auraient
conclu qu'il n'y avait pas de risque et
pourtant Monsieur Samuel Patier n'est
plus en 2014 le Parlement a intégré au
code pénal les délits de provocation à
la commission d'actes terroristes et
d'apologie du terrorisme et a créé
l'infraction d'entreprise individuelle
de terrorisme dès lors ces infractions
peuvent faire l'objet de techniques
spéciales d'enquête prévue par le code
de procédure pénale en 2015 nous avons
élargi et encadré les moyens d'action de
nos services de renseignement
malheureusement nous savons depuis les
attentats survenues la même année que
c'est la nature en rien le risque zéro
toutefois à l'observation de
l'enchaînement des actes conduisant à
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
ceci illustre dramatiquement le manque
de moyens consacrés à la mise en oeuvre
des dispositions légales moyen pourtant
nécessaire pour réagir de manière
adéquate au signaux qui aurait dû
alerter aussi Monsieur le Ministre
au-delà des effets d'annonce d'hier du
président de la République et du
gouvernement par quels moyens concret
humain et financier les pouvoirs publics
vont-ils être dotés afin de prévenir
plus efficacement à la Commission de
tels actes terroristes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre d'intérieur
monsieur sénateur
j'ai président pardon c'est le sénateur
je ne suis pas d'accord avec votre
constat et je m'en excuse
dans le budget encore proposé par
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ces 330
personnes de plus rien que pour les
services de renseignement
mais vous ne souhaitez pas rentrer dans
le débat et c'est ce que j'ai eu comme
débat madame Conway eu la gentillesse de
débattre avec moi à mon invitation au
nom du parti socialiste c'est le siège
dans vos rang elle peut en être témoin
c'était aussi votre cas puisque vous
étiez le rapport de votre groupe lorsque
je reprochais à madame la sénatrice
effectivement c'est un fait de pas
donner les moyens en votant les lois qui
nous permettent d'y arriver monsieur
monsieur le Center ne vous énervez pas
j'explique
nous manquons de moyens légaux
pardon de vous lire monsieur le sénateur
mais la vidéo mis en ligne par ce père
de famille je mets des guillemets mais
donc procureur a dit aujourd'hui qu'il
était le complice donc je peux me
permettre de le dire cet attentat
n'aurait pas pu être retiré avec la loi
de la République actuelle et ne pourrait
pas être tiré demain si une autre vidéo
arrivée
parce qu'elle est insidieuse elle n'est
pas une vidéo qui appelle directement à
l'assassinat elle était une vidéo
d'officine isamiste qui de façon
insidieuse
organise effectivement ce lien avec un
attentat terroriste donc oui il faut
renforcer la loi sur ce point monsieur
le sénateur les associations que je peux
présenter désormais dans des solutions
au Conseil des ministres à la demande du
Président de la République ne sont
possibles que par ce qu'il y a pour
certaines d'entre elles encore le
groupement de faits de ce matin rien
directe avec le terrorisme parce que
nous n'avons pas assez de moyens
juridique pour proposer ces dissolutions
parce que nous combattons le terrorisme
et pas l'islamisme politique dans la loi
française il faut modifier la loi de la
loi séparative que j'espère que vous
voterez et monsieur le sénateur ces
échanges qui ont lieu via les réseaux
sociaux n'aurait pas été possible si ne
serait pas possible pardon si nous
n'avons pas comme la très bien posé la
question de monsieur le Président
mallouret des moyens supplémentaires
pour lui lutter contre la haine en ligne
dans plus de moyens oui mais un
changement de loi on vous attend
la parole est à notre collègue Rémi
quintro pour le groupe les républicains
oui monsieur monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et pense sur les zones de
revitalisation rurale les Ederer madame
la ministre le 26 novembre 2019 avec mes
collègues Cora porteurs Frédéric
espagnol et Bernard dELCON nous vous
avions remis notre rapport sénatorial
portant sur l'avenir des etre parmi nos
recommandations il y avait avant tout
l'idée de proroger d'un an et demi soit
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 le dispositif
actuel afin de réfléchir à la réforme
des critères et aux mesures financières
associées en réponse nous vous nous
aviez dit non et vous avez proposé une
prorogation de seulement 6 mois jugeant
que vous aurez en si peu de temps la
possibilité de réformer l'ensemble des
critères de classement vous deviez
également vous inspirer du travail
sénatorial
malheureusement cette réforme n'a pas
encore vu le jour au point
qu'aujourd'hui vous seriez prête selon
certaines informations à projet le
système actuel jusqu'en 2022 si cela
s'avère être vrai je m'en réjouis mais
je constate que le Sénat a de nouveau eu
tort d'avoir raison trop tôt madame la
ministre durant la campagne c'est
notoriale tous les élus concernés par
les ZRR que j'ai rencontrés mon
manifester leurs inquiétude quant à
l'échéance des Ederer prévu à la fin de
l'année avec pour interrogation comment
peut-on parler d'un plan de relance
lequel contiendrait des mesures de
relocalisation alors que l'on s'apprête
à réduire encore et derrière qui comme
vous le savez favorise l'installation
des entreprises dans des territoires les
plus isolés alors mes questions sont
simples confirmez-vous la prorogation
jusqu'en 2022 si oui avez-vous élaboré
un calendrier sur l'étude des critères
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
musique de la cohésion des territoires
madame Gouraud
monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rémi.treau oui le Premier
ministre a décidé de prolonger les edrr
jusqu'en 2022 je l'ai dit la semaine
dernière à l'Assemblée nationale dans
une question d'actualité qui m'avait été
posée oui je me souviens très bien de
d'abord un du travail excellent que vous
avez fait avec Frédéric espanac et
Bernard delcro je me souviens très bien
déjà des questions qui m'avaient été
posées et je vous rappelle au passage
que nous avions déjà
conservé jusqu'à la fin de l'année
toutes les communes qui devaient sortir
au mois de juillet vous vous en souvenez
soit 4400 communes si j'ai le chiffre en
tête peut-être un précis mais je crois
que c'est cela mais nous avions dit que
vous n'avions voulions comme vous le
recommandiez dans votre rapport qui
disait que c'était un caractère
complexe et insuffisamment ciblé que les
aides erreurs et nous voulions
effectivement à la demande aussi des
mers ruraux et du secrétaire d'État Joel
Giraud essayez de faire une géographie
prioritaire de la ruralité plus ciblée
mais nous avons jugé le Premier ministre
à juger que le temps n'était pas assez
long pour mettre en place un nouveau
système que la crise du covid comme vous
l'avez ou de la covid que vous l'avez
dit à l'instant pour faire la relance et
très importante où les conséquences de
la crise de covid avec la relance est
très importante donc cette décision a
été prise par le Premier ministre et
bien sûr je suppose que cela vous
convient ce qui nous empêchera pas de
continuer à travailler comme nous avons
commencé à le faire notamment avec
l'INSEE pour définir une nouvelle
géographie dans les années qui viennent
monsieur Cointreau oui madame le
ministre je me réjouis de cette cette
annonce après l'Assemblée nationale
je suis bien sûr tout à fait heureux de
voir que vous allez remettre en route et
derrière mais absolument il faut que le
Sénat soit associé le Sénat est à la
maison des territoires et je pense que
ça serait tout à fait logique que nous
soyons associés à cette réflexion merci
la parole
est à notre Olivier caddic pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question au ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
portent sur la relation entre la Chine
et l'AFD l'Agence Française de
Développement vous connaissez les
réticences du Parlement qui se demandent
s'il AFD n'a pas d'autres priorités que
de prêter 250 millions d'euros à la
Chine pour sa transition écologique la
semaine dernière avec le concours du
président Cambon j'ai demandé en
audition au directeur général de lived
s'il n'était pas possible de redéployer
ses prêts à la Chine vers le monde
Indo-Pacifique où la France a besoin
d'accroître son influence relayant les
demandes des élus et de nos diplomates
du Pacifique le directeur de l'AFD c'est
justifié par une formule renversante je
gagne de l'argent en Chine mon salaire
est payé par les Chinois et de nous
décrire avec un geste circulaire que les
Chinois achètent des obligations émises
par l'AFD sur les marchés financiers
puis cet argent retourne ensuite en
Chine sous forme de près de l'AFD l'AFD
se commissionne au passage au de servir
la stratégie d'influence du régime
communiste chinois à l'international
cette situation de conflit d'intérêt est
consternante j'observe au quotidien les
difficultés de nos entrepreneurs qui se
battent à l'international et
particulièrement en Afrique ils sont
face à des compétiteurs chinois
utilisant des techniques commerciales
interdites par notre droit ce conflit
d'intérêt a fait réagir en particulier
nos collègues d'outre-mer Nassima Dindar
à la Réunion ou Gérard poète Jean aux
nouvelles Calédonie celui-ci m'a alerté
sur le prêt controversé de l'AFD en
Calédonie cela lourdeur des réformes
fiscales qui l'imposent et les
conditions opaques de sa conclusion je
cite Gérard poadja si l'influence de la
Chine dans cette organisme prêteur était
avérée cela ne serait pas neutre sur
l'avenir d'une partie du territoire
français stratégique pour la France
comme pour la Chine ma question pour ma
question est la suivante la politique
française au développement passe par
l'AFD comment pouvez-vous garantir que
l'AFD ne servent pas mal gré elle
d'autres intérêts que ceux de la France
quand le Parlement pourra-t-il disposer
d'un rapport d'évaluation de la relation
de l'AFD avec la Chine je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
de l'Europe des Affaires étrangères
Monsieur Le Drian monsieur le sénateur
Olivier Cadic le directeur général de
l'Agence française pour le développement
pense avoir le sens de l'humour
mais je dois vous dire que de mon point
de vue
sur de tel sujet et dans de tels lieux
la commission des affaires étrangères et
des forces armées du Sénat la boutade
n'est ni pertinente ni au Portugal
je vous tenais à vous le dire pour le
reste
oui la FD est présente en Chine mais
elle est présente en Chine parce que
c'est notre intérêt
je ne prendrai qu'un seul exemple climat
il est dans notre intérêt stratégique et
politique de bâtir des partenariats
permettant d'orienter le premier
émetteur de CO2 dans le monde vers une
économie bas carbone ne pas le faire
affaiblirait notre posture et nous
agissons ensemble avec la Chine sur ce
point pour lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique et de sur quoi j'observe que
cela présente des avantages pour les
entreprises françaises car la présence
de l'AFD et de ses outils bancaires dans
ce pays sur ces sujets là est un
valorisation et ça permet de faire
valoir leur expertise et leur
attractivité donc c'est en fonction de
nos intérêts
mais j'ajoute que sur la Chine
il n'y a en aucun cas de subvention et
que la Chine ne reçoit de la France que
des prêts non concessionnelles et aux
conditions du marché mais je suis tout à
fait favorable à ce qu'il y ait une
présentation globale de notre présence
en Chine de différentes manières vous
savez la Chine elle est à la fois notre
partenaire notre concurrent et notre
rival et il faut décliner ces trois
aspects avec beaucoup de vigilance mais
en même temps en faisant en permanence
valoir notre propre nos propres intérêts
et notre propre souveraineté c'est comme
ça que je conçois la relation avec la
Chine qui passe par de la fermeté de la
transparence de la détermination et vous
savez que j'en suis capable
merci la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
Ravier pour les sénateurs de figurants
sur la liste d'aucun groupe vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le ministre la
barbarie est à nos portes nous a dit le
ministre de la Justice quel inquiétante
affirmation en réalité pour vous la
barbarie ne serait qu'un au port quand
des gamins se font tirer dessus au
Bataclan des familles se font écraser à
Nice que des passants se font poignarder
des profs décapités la réalité c'est que
les barbares sont là parmi nous et qu'en
plus nous n'avons plus de porte à fermer
vous avez tous retiré mes chers
collègues de droite comme de gauche
toutes les barrières toutes les
frontières ce que vous appelez
timidement le désordre migratoire mais
qui est en réalité une anarchie une
déferlante migratoire vous en êtes tous
responsables à droite peut-être
davantage car je rappelle que c'est
Nicolas Sarkozy qui a aboli la double
peine c'est lui qui entretenait les
meilleurs rapports avec le kata c'est
sous sa présidence que l'immigration a
atteint notre corps mes chers collègues
de droite beaucoup de mentent
aujourd'hui sont autant indécents qui
nous disent aujourd'hui les terroristes
bénéficient de notre giron de notre
générosité pour connaître leurs
abominations le Bataclan des migrants le
roi et Moran à Marseille un clandestin
tunisien l'attaque de Romans-sur-Isère
en avril un réfugiés soudané l'attaque
de Charlie Hebdo le mois dernier un faux
mineur isolé pakistanais et la semaine
dernière réfugiés tchétchéna chaque fois
c'est la même chose la même explication
la politique d'immigration anarchique
tue des Français des terroristes
d'importation tue les innocents mais
dans la classe politique c'est le grand
silence impossible pour vous d'avouer
que la politique d'immigration loin
d'être une chance est un véritable fléau
il faut pourtant la stopper elle coûte
trop de vie à la France vous avez épuisé
votre crédit communication monsieur le
ministre il s'agit désormais d'agir pour
sauver des vies malgré les insultes et
les violences le mouvement national
auquel j'appartiens vous alerte
inlassablement depuis des décennies
aujourd'hui qu'il est douloureux d'avoir
résonance et conditions vous nous avez
dit femme et diabolisées haï pour
aujourd'hui nous donner des raisons en
tout à l'heure ma question monsieur le
ministre la voilà allez-vous oui ou non
stoppez l'immigration et renvoyer dans
leur pays ces centaines de milliers
d'étrangers qui n'ont rien à faire chez
nous
la parole pour vous répondre est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur ravier
le moment est trop grave pour faire de
la polémique puisque dans je ne vous
vois pas monsieur c'est moi pour faire
de la polémique et je voudrais pas
rentrer dans le en réponse avec le même
ton que vous avez posé votre question et
n'y voyez pas la condescendance mais sur
le fond je vais essayer de répondre à
votre question vous avez vu que les
attentats
tous horribles
tout signal
tout ce que mis au nom d'une idéologie
islamisme radicale
mais il est faux monsieur le sénateur et
je lis devant une chambre qui représente
la nation française de dire que ce ne
sont que des étrangers qui ont commis
ces actes
sur les 19 derniers attentat
c'est-à-dire tous les attentats qui ont
lieu depuis 2017 j'essaie d'être le plus
objectif possible
9 étrangers 22 français
il faut monsieur le sénateur que bien
sûr on pose la question des étrangers
qui sont en situation de radicalisation
et je partage d'opinion j'imagine la
plus communément partagée par le bon
sens populaire et parce qu'il est
représentent qu'il faut expulser du
territoire national toute personne qui
trouble profondément dans le grand
public c'est la loi de la République et
les gens qui sont radicalisés et qui
n'appartiennent pas à la nation
française évidemment pour plein de
raisons on évoquait que c'est notre
Hervé et ça peut être un manque de
volonté un manque de moyens ça peut être
aussi des difficultés on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler expulser sur des
territoires en guerre en Libye ou en
Syrie les gens qui sont arrivés sur le
sol national et légèrement difficile
vous en conviendrez avec moi
mais il y a aussi des français né en
France parfois de parents français
parfois français j'aimerais pas parler
comme vous parler de temps en temps
monsieur sénateur mais depuis très
longtemps parfois plus depuis plus
longtemps que ma propre famille qui sont
allés en Syrie qui se sont convertis et
qui commettent des attentats ignobles
donc oui il y a des étrangers
radicalisés mais éliminer les étrangers
n'éminera pas la radicalisation de cette
sénateur
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs du ministre merci
chers collègues je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement auront lieu le mercredi 28
octobre à 15h je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h45 pour
l'annonce du scrutin pour l'élection de
6 juif titulaire et si juge suppléant à
la Cour de Justice de la République puis
pour la
[Musique]